I got a buddy who's like man had a chick
over last night had sex with her hour
and a half and I tell him she doesn't
want that dude and he says no not the
way I do it like he viciously believes
that he's right and you know the the the
girl is just the whole time just like in
her head just like my God this is
long but she's still got to be like yeah
yeah oh yeah you know and he's just
working away she doesn't want it he
probably doesn't even want it either you
know he's just like sweating so hard on
his couch in his one
bedroom dude an hour we had and they'll
still tell me this i' for years I've
been telling them dude she does they
don't want that an hour
dude you're exhausted at the end of it I
know we've talked about this early early
on in the congratulations archives the
top time to have sex is 12 minutes dude
that's the top amount of time the the
peak most enjoyable
shits or
less sometimes 12 is too long busting 6
and
A2 it's just crazy dude dudes think like
nah man I'm gonna turn her out my
favorite other guys that like you know
this has happened where they're just
like dude I'm GNA [__] like my favorite
is a guy that like thinking you know how
like everything's happened in the world
everything in the world has happened
because it's just like been around for
so
long like
there like I love thinking about a guy
being like baby I'm gonna [__] you all
night and she's like okay and he's like
hell yeah all night here we go and just
slides in and
just just can't even hold it at all and
just absolutely explodes
immediately ah sweet I'm G to [__] you
all night oh yeah yep here we
go oh
[Music]
God and he impregnates her and it's just
a [__] the worst life later you know
they don't even like each
other yeah how's that for [__] all
night huh give me a heads up next time
you splurt it inside and now we've got a
kid that won't talk to me and I hate
you all from a dude just thinking he's
going to rock it oh dude I'm gonna rock
it when I have sex I rock it dude not me
I'm not good at it not me I'm not good
at it at all but that's what makes me
good at it you can't care too much dude
he truly can't my buddy cares too much
and I just know he's not good I know
he's not good part of me wants to shift
into a woman to see just to see what
it's like right cuz I could have him do
my butt but not really though because
it's different man I'm not into it but
if I was a woman I'd be into it I really
want to see what he's like dude how how
dope would that be if you were a woman
you could just test out some men without
being gay just seeing what's up just
rank them you know what in the text chat
light it up you know just I got I got a
text chat with five dudes in there they
all think they're Alphas dude let me
just shift into a lady and just just
absolutely laid down for all of them and
then come back as a man and rank them
all dude the roast sessions would be
insane do you know what I'm talking
about oh yeah you [__] for an hour
dude you should do it for two minutes
that's how bad it was do you know what
I'm
[Music]
saying just
like I don't know what do you think
women down there I want to see the
comments even though I won't look what
how how long is the best amount for sex
argue with yourselves I say 12 minutes I
say 7 to 12 minutes ah 7 Minutes kind of
short
honestly 12 minutes I say I've always
said 12 minutes at 4:30 p.m. with the
[__] leaf blower going off in the
background no music my wife goes like
this can we ever start playing music
when when we have sex and I go I say if
you want like what do you want to play
the weekend or some [__] you
know what do you
play the weekend like what do you play
when you [__] what are you supposed
supposed to do put on Phil Collins One
More
Night One More Night
[Music]
o that's a problem though if you got the
iPod Shuffle or whatever on and then you
play it and it's just like one more
night and then [__] Lean Back comes
on and you're like all right the whole
mood changed never mind or some jiss
starts you know or or even worse like
the [__] Comedy album that from Mitch
fatel that you downloaded in
2008 um but yeah dude it's just uh I
don't know man stop trying so hard